hey peta go away nobody likes you
you don't like you
i hate my life peter's most recent pr
stunt involved them dressing up like the
kkk
protesting outside the westminster dog
show no more
dog shows we liked animals
huh okay that's that's clever so what's
the parallel you're drawing here
what well you're dressed up as klansmen
what's the comparison what's the
comparison
yeah i don't think dogs should have to
sniff drugs man
i guess peta says that the american
kennel club is just like the kkk
and that they're seeking to produce one
master race congratulations peter you've
managed to compare the epic historical
struggle and plight of the jews and
blacks to that of pampered show dogs
listen peta everyone loves animals but
you guys just come off as bullies
ruben get back in your kennel
don't worry it's a nice kennel maybe not
as luxurious as club gitmo but you know
nice like i said nearly everyone loves
animals which is why you've accomplished
the impossible in turning
everybody against your cause nobody's
against your pro-animal agenda it's that
your message is ultimately anti-human
you're the type of people who after
hurricane katrina demand the priority
rescue of animals while there are still
women and children to be saved the type
of people who couldn't care less about
an innocent lady being beheaded in the
name of allah but will mourn the death
of a chimpanzee shot while tearing off a
lady's face amidst a red wine and xanax
bender
i understand that your stunts are meant
to be thought-provoking or somehow be
ironic oh which reminds me of a joke
i've got for you okay
what's the difference between a cow and
a chicken
i don't know but i indiscriminately eat
both their flesh on a regular basis
and if you want to bring people to your
way of thinking please ditch the
celebrity bee listers
alicia silverstone batman and robin
pamela anderson
are you trying to repel us you want to
build a movement get someone like tom
cruise to endorse you
peta you'll find is uh
a very very good organization when you
have done the research
as i have done the research don't eat
meat i'm trying to help you
help me help you now why would you eat
meat
why would you do that you're a jerk
you're a jerk
i feel the need the need for ethical
treatment
of animals
if you eat meat i'm gonna be very very
upset
and you haven't seen me very upset
anyways peter you can do whatever you
want everybody has the right to free
speech
which is why i'm introducing meat weak
everybody out there do as i'm going to
do this week and measurably increase
your meat intake by a significant amount
leave a response telling me why and what
you love about meat then continue to
list your meat escapades throughout the
week it'll be a collective meat
journal reuben okay that one was
preemptive
sorry but i've got to go make my
afternoon protein shake
start with some milk now i don't really
believe in soy protein
nobody wants moobs chicken corned beef
pastrami double burger
could use some veal